Diddy is on trial. He faces federal
charges for sex trafficking,
racketeering, and much more. But the
darkness in his world goes much deeper
than anyone could have ever imagined.
Rob Long produced for Diddy in his
studio. He went to his house, stayed at
his mansion. He even crossed paths with
Mary J. Blige and Ti. But what he
witnessed some artists do is crazy. He
saw full-on rituals with candles being
lit, hands waved in certain patterns,
and chants were spoken over the beats.
Those were seances, summoning the demons
to help them produce that music. The
pressure in this demonic realm nearly
drove Rod mad. He had to get out of
Diddy's circle. And when he did leave
without telling anybody, they threatened
him. Now, Rod is exposing not only what
goes on in the hip-hop and R&B world,
but it also happens in the Christian
music industry as well. So, Diddy Trial
is ongoing and there's uh news dripping
out every single day about updates in
the in the trial. Um some really sad
stuff that we're hearing coming from
this. Um but you know, another
individual that's kind of coming up
again is Rong. He's making his rounds.
He is a former Diddy producer and he
actually became a Christian. I think he
also became a pastor and he's making his
rounds around Christian podcast to talk
about his experiences when he was with
Diddy and why he left the music industry
and he talks about some pretty dark
stuff. So I want to take a look at this
and let's respond. Puffy heard a record.
He was like I want it. He cut us a
check. I was on top of the world.
Actually, Puffy called and said, "Hey,
let's bring these guys to New York."
Yeah. Mary J. Lodge and a bunch of It
was crazy. The Lord spoke to me clearly.
He said, "Don't touch hip hop and R&B."
It's highly demonic. If you're going to
do it on a high level, you're going to
have to tap into something else.
Nobody's doing it on a high level and
they're in perfect communion with God.
It just doesn't happen. I had to alter
my mind. Now I could hear. I had a
record with the the game was on TI. I
felt like I created something that was a
vehicle for a message that was from the
Dark Kingdom. Murderous. I created a
vehicle for this message to ride on.
I'm at a party. Dr. Dre is there. A
bunch of high-profile people are there.
And I left there. And that's when the
phone call started. The threats, hey,
where are you? They called my church.
They actually showed up at my church.
There ain't no way these demons come out
and they like, "We got you. You going to
hell now." When we're in the presence of
the Lord in worship, it opens doors. It
absolutely opens doors. Well, if we're
on the other side, it's still opening
doors. It's just different doors. It's
one spirit realm. Now, what spirit
you're yielding to and what doors you're
opening is going to depend on what
you're saying.
Yeah. That's pretty wild, right? Yeah.
It's like that we've been talking about
this this whole time. like this this our
show talks a lot about what's happening
and now you hear it from the horse's
mouth. Yeah, he was on the top man. Mary
Jay Blige, P. Diddy, you know, all these
other people. He's I don't think it's
possible to get to those levels without
having some sort of connection. Like he
said, I actually totally believe that.
Like you may dance around the edges of
the industry, but you will not get to
that high A-list level without signing
up. Yeah. And I think I think the devil
can't afford for you to do that. Like if
if if you know the truth and all of a
sudden you get put in that position, you
you know, you've got a lot of influence
in that position. So he's he's making
sure he has those people secure before
he's giving them that that spotlight.
Mhm. Yeah. And I know you you worked in
the industry in in Hollywood more in
like the acting and and movie industry
and TV, but you never got to that top
level. Okay. So, I was on the very very
edge, right? But you wanted to I mean I
think uh you know everybody that goes
there with the intent of trying to make
it successful in there wants to be
there. It's just that you are unaware of
what you have to go through to get to
that and I was naive about that. Yeah.
And I think, you know, it would have
surprised me if it's kind of like this
the system of the frog in a pot that's
like slowly you turn up the heat and I
bet you at some point when those people
get to the top they're like how did I
even get here? You know, but then it's
too late. It's like look they don't
think they can come back from it, right?
Or it's like you do this or you you're
Somebody commented on um our channel one
time. We were talking about music and um
they said that they were uh noticed at a
public venue. They went and they sung
somewhere and then all of a sudden um
this person um approached them and I
can't remember who they were supposed to
be opening for but it was somebody like
Brandy or or you know it was kind of
like an R&B hip hoppy um type person or
no Cheryl Crowe that's what it was and
um was going to be an opening act for
that and they gave this person like one
song that she was able to sing you know
and and and it was this like super hard
complex song that she said she just
normally couldn't sing like that. And
then she said that right after that the
producers and stuff said if you want to
continue forward um you know like you
have to do this and this and this. What
was it? I have to dig up the comment but
um it was pretty interesting. They made
this statement that was saying the
demonic world will test you, give you
the ability like sing notes and things
that you can't have, give you a taste of
the fame and then back off and be like,
you know, if you want to get to hear,
will you um subject yourself to that or
not? It was a fascinating comment
somebody wrote on there. I'll have to
dig it up and share it. Yeah, it sounds
like full-on manipulation right there.
Well, it's like it's like I you know, I
think there's a good reason why some of
these people are so talented. I mean, I
I I think you're you're dealing with
something that's even giving them the
talent to do that. I mean, we've heard
that from rock bands, right? Did
couldn't play the guitar, went and sold
their soul of the devil and now they
could play the guitar. Same thing with
the voice, you know, you got you got
Beyonce talking about inviting a spirit
and and uh when the thing came inside of
her, she could sing notes that she
couldn't sing. So, I I think there is
just like what he said, there is a
demonic force that is all behind this.
Mhm. Yeah. Well, let's take a take a
look at what else he says about working
with Diddy and and what it was like for
him. Did produce some some records for
Diddy. I moved to New York for a while
and worked at what was called Daddy's
House Recording Studios, which is P.
Diddy's record label. There was so many
layers to a guy that powerful and a guy
that high up in the industry. You know,
he would come in and listen to the
music, listen to the work. He did have
an inner circle and you know you'd have
to go through the different levels of
trust. The spiritual implication for
feeding on that music is definitely
detrimental to your to your spiritual
life is definitely antirist. It comes
from people and entities higher than
diddy or higher than any human. From the
sounds to the lyrics is definitely
coming from the spiritual realm and it's
coming from Satan himself. They use
different mediums to take them out of
their normal mind so that they can be
vessels so that they can hear properly
to hear good music. They are totally
aware of what's going on. They're
cooperating and working with different
spiritual entities to produce messages
that will affect people spiritually.
I've been in rooms to where I've seen
the chants, the the seances, the same
rituals that you see in, let's say, film
making or Hollywood. It it's the same
rituals that you would see in the music
industry. I believe it 100%. I I totally
do. You know, I think that you have to
to be involved in this cuz cuz all Satan
does is counterfeit God, right? And and
and how does God work through his
servants, right? the Holy Spirit comes
in and and helps that pastor, you know,
piece together the right thoughts or
words to say. Um, you know, a lot of
times that's why we pray, Lord, you
know, put your words in my mouth and and
and those kind of things. And and so the
devil's doing that same sort of thing.
This is his church. The entertainment
industry is the church for how the devil
is passing information. Wasn't it Ariana
Grande who for the for the movie Wicked,
she was on set like doing tarot readings
with people? Mhm. She we did an we we
had a clip where we showed an interview
and she I remember her claiming you know
she was a witch the witch witchiest
witch. Yeah the witchiest witch like
multiple times and she she was talking
about that whole interaction the tarot
card readings I don't I don't remember I
remember that she did say she said on
set when people found out that she did
that they would come to her. Yeah. Yeah.
It was in that same interview. Yeah.
Something I want to uh that I noticed
here. It seems that like the higher you
get in ranking of like success, the more
demonics your music videos or lyrics
seems to be. Very true. You got Jay-Z,
you got little I mean Lil X started like
you know doing lap dances on the on the
devil. Yeah. For one of his songs. It's
like the the higher you get the more
demonic it seems to be. And I don't
think that's for no reason, right? It's
just like it gets really weird, I would
say, because you don't really find that
with like smaller artists.
Like why would that why why would they
even bother doing that? Well, and I
think too that like I don't want to say
every single person who's involved in
the music industry is possessed or is
doing stuff for Satan. I don't think
that's the case. I think especially like
you were working in Hollywood. You
weren't dealing with that kind of stuff.
You know, when I think when you're lower
on the totem pole or on the ladder, you
are probably just genuinely like I just
want to live this lifestyle. But I think
once you get higher up, that's when you
see like in Matthew 4 where Satan is
like, hey, I'll give you the whole world
if you bow down and worship me. Mhm. And
I think if he did that to Jesus, why
would he not do that to every single
other person on this earth who is Jesus
wasn't even desiring that, right, to bow
down and he he already was he already
owned the world. He created the world.
But for everybody else, it's like, well,
now you got to choose. And like I said,
I think it is a frog in the pot kind of
a system where you slowly turn up the
heat where at some point you're like,
how did it even end up here? But then it
might be too late. You might be too much
involved. There might be things like
happening with with Diddy where there's
a lot of abuse happening. There's
blackmailing and it's like you can't get
out. You feel stuck and you keep going
and well it's a satanic world at that
point. Mhm. It's slavery. Yeah. Is
basically what they're saying in Diddy's
world. The people that were surrounded
around him were essentially like slaves.
Mhm. I can see that for sure. Yeah. So
he also talks a little bit about what
happens in the music industry. So let's
take a look what happens in the music
industry.
The people who were able to get to a
certain level on their own or who had
special giftings or talents or abilities
from from God because every good and
perfect gift does come from the Lord.
But Satan is watching. He's watching um
different artists. Whatever your gifting
may be, he's watching. And when you get
to a certain level on your own, you'll
reach a gatekeeper. And that gatekeeper,
they will come to you and they will say,
"Hey, if you want to get to the next
level, here's what you have to do.
Here's the sacrifices that you have to
make." So the the people who are, you
know, at at these very very high levels,
they went through some rituals. Whether
it was the ritual of homosexuality,
whether it was um blood sacrificing,
there was some type of ritual that
allowed them to cross over into these
very, very high realms. And that came
with something called an obligation,
which a lot of of um preachers that are
on the dark side as well that have sold
their soul and have uh done different
rituals to prophesy. Even in gospel
music, there's, you know, homosexuality.
There's, you know, it it's it's riddled
with all types of of of of rituals. I
believe it. I really believe it. I I
don't think that this guy having been
that high up, having been surrounded by
those people, having sat in a recording
room with P. Diddy and and made music
for him would just take this out of thin
air. There's enough evidence where
people have come forward and talked
about the use of witchcraft. I mean, we
have the out of the horse's mouth
themselves talking about that. Yeah. And
you know, remember, do if you guys saw
like in the news um or or trending on on
um um YouTube was uh Beyonce's drummer.
Do you remember her filing a restraining
order because she said that Beyonce was
doing extreme witchcraft against? Same
same for um the other singer. Oh, Lady
Gaga. Lady Gaga. Yes. Lady Gaga also her
personal assistant, I think, cuz she
made her personal assistant sleep in the
bed with her because she said, "I've got
all these demons in me and I need you to
sleep with me cuz I'm scared." Or
something like that. Yep. So, I think
that when you have all these different
people and you kind of see them talking
about those issues, I guarantee you that
probably almost everybody at that point
has has, you know, done things that that
cross the line and now they're over
there. Yeah, I I believe it 100%. Um,
and he wouldn't be saying that just to
say. Honestly, I don't think he
needs to say any of that or makes money
out of just spreading rumors. Let's say
if it if that would be the case. He's a
pastor now from what I understand. And,
you know, he he's working in ministry
right now. He wouldn't need to be saying
all of that, just create rumors or make
any money out of that. So, like he he
knows this stuff. He understands this
stuff. saw this stuff and you're just
bringing out a word of warning to
everyone because you know there are
people out there that say a bunch of
stuff with no back backup or anything
like that but he was in that lifestyle
he saw everything that happened and you
know I would I would say he's a pretty
trustworthy source because he was right
there right I agree yeah I think another
interesting source to look at is Kanye
uh when he was still a Christian or you
know said that he was still living in
the Christian lifestyle and you know he
did these Sunday services. He made a
pretty interesting statement. It's at
the Sunday services. It's very sad that
he left that and left his faith. But
let's uh go back in time and see what he
has to say at the Sunday service he was
putting up. God using us to show off to
show God
is better than the devil. The devil to
all the producers, the musicians, the
designers.
moved us all out to Hollywood, moved us
all out to New York, chasing gold
statues.
Literally signing a contract and selling
our souls. They got contracts out there
that say you can't say Jesus. When we
was working on this album, people used
to be coming over to studio just to say
Jesus as loud as they wanted to. You can
say Jesus in your studio.
[Music]
Wow. Interesting. I mean, like he's like
he was on the top and still is
technically on top of the world when it
comes to fame and the celebrity thing. I
mean, he's like the most popular
well-known A-list celebrity and
musician. And then he says this, and I'm
I'm surprised not more people have
actually paid attention to what he was
saying here. Do you remember the clip
where um some paparazzi were um um
interviewing him when he was getting in
his car and they were asking him, you
know, like like like now that the
industry is turning against you um you
know, are you are you scared of that or
whatever? And he said, "No, I I didn't
do the sacrifice." And then he named off
the other people that did that. He named
off I think LeBron James. He named off
Jay-Z and his wife and all these people
that had done these like ritualistic
sacrifices because this is a counterfeit
of God, right? We are we are called to
take up the cross and basically
a sacrifice of our own self and then
following after Jesus and the devil's
requiring the same thing but instead of
sacrificing yourself he's making them
sacrifice a loved one which is the
opposite end of the spectrum right Bible
says um that that no greater love is
that a man would lay down his life for
his friend right that's how heaven
operates that you yourself would lay
down your life so that somebody else
could have a better life. That was
Jesus. And what the what the satanic
side of that does is you need to
sacrifice someone that you love that's
closest to you so you can move up. And
that's just a super evil. I mean, if you
if you're willing to sacrifice your mom,
your kid, your your somebody like that
just so you could make more money and do
that, there's probably no end to that
evil that you would be a part of. Yeah.
Uh and also to think of in the Old
Testament of course we have the
sacrificial system which died with Jesus
on the cross cuz he was the fulfillment
of that system. In the Old Testament
they have to sacrifice animals as part
of the sanctuary services. Um which you
know there were various animals but a
lamb among them. And then John 1:29
Jesus by John the Baptist is called
behold the lamb of God who takes away
the sin of the world. So he was the
fulfillment of that. You have the type
and you have the anti-ype. And so that
sacrificial system is very biblical like
you're saying. And then also now with
like you you surrender yourself to God,
you know, give yourself a living your
bodies as a living sacrifice. Not
literally like I'm going to cut my own
throat, but spiritually speaking. That's
right. And the satanic version of that
is I mean we see it in the Bible. We see
it when they were giving their children
up to Baal and burning burning them on
the altars of Baal. So the devil's
taking what God has designed as
something that should illustrate that
now that that sin happened there. You
need a savior and he's just flipping
that model and now putting your kids on
that altar and killing them. Like it's
just perversion. Yeah. And he was saying
uh that that they're chasing gold
statues, which is interesting. I wonder
if he saw our video. How cool would that
be? Kanye, if you can hear this, please
come on our channel. I want to know if
you've seen our video.
Um, so are you guys familiar with Roger
Mno? Oh, yeah. Yeah. So, as Keith, who
was Roger Mell? He was a French Canadian
who lived
many years ago, but he was probably more
active in the 70s and ' 80s. As far as
his ministry goes, is a
a retail sales well kind of a a
salesman. He sold uh advertising space
to um telephone or to businesses to be
in like yellow pages and stuff which
have you ever seen a yellow pages? Oh,
I'm not I'm not that young. Come on.
Have you seen a yellow pages? I've heard
of them. Okay. You've heard of them.
There was this big I have used it. I
have used it. Yeah. Big thick book. And
they got smaller as time went on. But
anyway, he was in merchant marines and
he was kind of dabbling in in all kinds
of things and at one point he got
selected to be um invited to parties and
stuff and
more or less tapped to be a a Satanist.
And as he got deeper and deeper and
deeper into it, just before he got taken
to his oath, he started doing Bible
studies with somebody. And he quickly
saw that if I if if this is a very
powerful entity over here, how powerful
is God? And he realized how powerful God
was. And so God delivered him through
many circumstances, but he was like
right on the edge of becoming a like a
satanic priest. Mhm. And uh chose to
give that up and and surrender to to God
instead. But yeah, because of that, he
saw a lot of stuff. Yep. Heard a lot of
stuff.
So, uh, some of that stuff that he saw
and heard, he, uh, when he was still
alive, he would do interviews or, you
know, people asked if they could
interview him and he would share his
testimony and what he saw. Uh, he
obviously talks about the music industry
as well. He said in this in this clip,
just to give a bit of a preface, he was
uh, invited, this was just before he
actually started going to seances and
which led to Satanism. He was invited to
go to a restaurant. He was there with
the famous band member and uh he walked
into the restaurant and uh the
restaurant was full but as soon as they
saw the band member they made room for
him somewhere somehow and Roger's like
how do you how do you get here like how
why are you so famous and he assumed it
was just skill but it's not listen to
what is being said in this conversation
and he says how do you think that I
became famous the way that I am
when I said you must have had some good
luck. What he says there's no such thing
as good luck. He says there's either
some power working for you somewhere or
you don't get ahead in this world. Not
in my my type of occupation.
So, um
it went from there. We went we got
talking about spirit worship.
Did it intrigue you? Was it make you
want to find out more about what exactly
he was talking about? Yeah.
So
he said the the supposed spirits of the
dead that you're talking with are demon
spirits.
They're fallen angels.
They're beautiful beings. Just set it
out just like that. Oh, yeah. Wow. So,
do do you know these uh the people that
interviewed him? Yes. Pastor Jamie's
parents and we had him on there when he
talked about the um climate change
stuff, but this is his parents. Yeah.
Cool. And it was in the 80s that that uh
that they did this interview. Small
world. Yeah. Yeah. So again, uh it's
coming from multiple sides, right?
People are the multiple sides are saying
like, "Yeah, this is what's happening.
You got to sell your soul." And you
know, it's interesting how you you even
hear it more from the music industry. So
for example, this is from a website
called called thatgraju.net. This is
talking about Rihanna and it says,
"Since hitting the net last week,
reviews have been split down the
middle." This is talking about one of
Rihanna's uh albums that she released a
couple years ago. Although some like
singer Tiffany Evans are delving deeper
into the song's true concept. Evans
blasted Rihanna via Twitter for what she
sees as glorification of what? Suicide
and devil worship. There's another this
this this singer named Tiffany Evans is
is basically blasting Rihanna saying
like your new album is about suicide and
devil worship. So they spoke with Evans
former label mate Omaron and Omaran
shared his thoughts and he says I don't
personally know Rihanna's beliefs but I
think there's a very dark and very
sinister part of the entertainment
business and I think it's very visible.
This is something that a lot of people
don't look at. For example, Michael
Jackson, this this is so wild. He used
to be a Jehovah's Witness and I remember
hearing that we wanted to that he wanted
to separate from the religion and this
was during the time that he was doing
Thriller which ended up being his
biggest album. Thriller is fullon dark
man right. Yeah. I mean you just think
about how many really big famous artists
have said something within connection to
the devil or you know spirits or
something like this. I mean, you could
just go down the list and and and I bet
you you could probably find one or two
or even albums that that every single
top celebrity has done and it's more
glorifying darkness than it is light. I
mean, you go down this path and you
realize that at a certain point you
cannot take God or religion with you.
Yeah. And at that I think that's the
moment where you you make a choice. you
either sacrifice your own dreams for
God's dreams or you sacrifice, you know,
God and your relationship with him to
follow your own dreams. And and that's
something that you see with every um
celebrity that makes it up there. You
know, it seems like they all have to
make this decision to sell their soul
and, you know, put God aside and all
that. There's no middle ground. You
can't serve two masters. Yeah, that's
the idea. It's one or the other. Um so,
let's continue. Fast forward to now.
Marion continued, "And it really made me
think that there is a time as an artist
where there's going to be a choice.
We've talked about this the whole time.
The entertainment world dictates that
you have to be with three or four women
or do this in order to get that." And I
think it's really interesting with God
and the industry. It's really dark. The
dark side is having to get in. There's a
certain submission you need to have just
like a gang initiation, so to speak. You
might have to do something against your
moral code. I'm not saying that it is
always this way, but when you're someone
that is young and you're coming up in
the industry and you really don't have a
grip on your morals, it can be dark. The
game is just about oversaturation.
Is anything he says about like if you're
being if you're young and you're coming
into an industry and didn't know
anything kind of like Justin Bieber,
right? like he came in super young and
look how Diddy looks very much like he
took advantage of that in some of the
clips that we've seen about Diddy and
Justin Bieber together was blackmail
and it's the exact opposite of what God
is trying to do. God is is out there
saying, you know, let me cover what's
happened to you
and let let me let me hide that because
so that nobody else has to see it. I
know that you did it, but I'm I'm not
out here to expose you to everything.
Right. And Satan has the exact opposite
tactic. He's like, you know, give me
something and then I'm gonna use it
against you. Yep. And I'm going to keep
escalating it. Fact, there's a I'm going
to Well, I'm going to probably do a show
on this, but there's a there's a cult
right now that's targeting young people
and they're doing the same exact tactic.
They're really good with technology.
They get in, they try to get the kid to
they either get something on them or
find something out about them that's
embarrassing or they don't want people
to know and they use that to keep
escalating them to do more disturbing
and disgusting things.
And if you look at how, like you were
saying, Keith, how God works versus how
Satan works is that people like to say,
"Oh, God, you know, you're always stuck.
You can't do this. You can't do that."
is a religion of the don'ts, right? If
you follow God. But if you look at, you
know, the examples that we're seeing
here, God is never the one who's like
binding you up with change. No, you
can't leave me. No, you can't do this or
that will happen. I mean, like, of
course, there are consequences to the
actions of of sin. But here's where we
see that Satan won't let you go because
this will happen, that will happen. Even
before you give yourself to Satan, you
have to do stuff that he will keep you
stuck there. So, you know what is really
who really gives you freedom? The Bible
says that love covers a multitude of
sins. And in essence, all these people
are doing is you're choosing you're
every day you're choosing your
testimony. Mhm. Mhm. What's your
testimony going to mean?
I'm sorry. Do we know each other? It
seems like maybe we've met before. I
don't know. This is uh it's awkward
though, just as much for me as it is for
you. I really wish I had a conversation
starter.
[Music]
Oh, hey. Oh, what's on my shirt? Yeah,
this is the story of the three angels
message from Revelation 14. Wow, that
totally worked. You know, if you have
trouble starting conversations like me,
maybe you should try Lightwear.
[Music]
I think also hearing a statement of
somebody say that I made you sign a
contract so that you can't use the name
of Jesus tells me that the name of Jesus
must be pretty powerful. They're going
to take that out of your mouth and not
allow you to use Jesus's name. There's
name in his there's power in his name.
Muhammad or Buddha or Krishna or anybody
else in there? I mean, yeah. It's like
they don't make you sign for that. Hindu
god. No doubt. Satan in there. That's
true. You can use the word Satan. I
mean, yeah, that's an interesting point.
Yeah. Have you guys ever seen this old
clip of Bob Dylan where he talks about
who he had to serve to get famous? Mhm.
So, take a look at this.
Why do you still do it? Why are you
still out here? Well, it goes back to
the destiny thing. I mean, I made a
bargain with it, you know, long time
ago, and I'm holding up my hand. What
was your bargain? To get where um I am
now. Should I ask who you made the
bargain with
with with with you know, with the chief
uh chief commander on this earth? On
this earth. in that in the world we
can't see. You ever look at music that
you've written and look back at it and
say, "Whoa, that surprised me.
I used to. Uh I I I don't do that
anymore. Uh I don't know how I got to to
write those songs." What do you mean you
don't know how? Well, those early songs
were like almost magically written. Um
uh darkness at the brick and noon
shadows even the silver spoon handmade
blade a child's balloon eclipses both
the sun and moon to understand you know
too soon there is no sense in trying
this Dylan classic it's all right ma was
written in 1964
the hollow horn plays wasted words
proves to warn that he not busy being
born is busy dying well try to sit down
want to write something like that. Uh
that there's a magic to that and it's
not uh sick freeden roy kind of magic,
you know. It's a it's a different kind
of a penetrating magic
and uh you know I did it I I did it at
one time. You don't think you can do it
today?
Mhm. Does that disappoint you?
Well, you can't do something forever and
uh I did it once and
I can do other things now, but
I can't do that. See, I think even the
top celebrities recognize that that that
talent which is that extra special
thing. Yeah. I is only probably gifted
to them while they're working with him.
When they get old and tired, those guys
the demonic world probably moves on to
somebody else and that somebody else.
But that's that's a pretty fascinating
clip right there. Yeah. Why but but like
you're saying like why limit your
resources on this one person when you
can move on to somebody else, right? Um
you know, we see a similar story with
Robert Johnson. You talked about this a
little bit like going to the crossroads
and when you can't play the guitar and
you sell your soul and then this
happens. Well, Robert Johnson was like
that too, uh unfortunately. And Netflix
actually made a show about him. So, I
just want to show you the trailer
because that really just easily explains
his story.
Robert Johnson is considered one of the
greatest blues artists of all time. It's
the template for what became rock and
roll. I believe Robert Johnson was
extremely talented, extremely gifted and
way off balance. Something's spinning
strangely in that man's life. Robert was
a novice guitar player, not very good.
This man was a nobody. And then he
disappears.
A year and a half later, he's doing
things with the guitar that even his
mentors can't do.
How could Robert possibly have gotten
that good that fast?
The myth goes Robert went to a
crossroads, got down on his knees, hand
his good tie to the devil. The devil
said once you receive this good tie
back, your soul is mine.
If you do make a deal with the devil,
you going to have to pay the price. It
ended up costing him the bill coming
due. He let his arrogance go too far. We
all have to choose how much we can
sacrifice in order to achieve greatness.
Lay it out there right before you. Mhm.
These things are happening over and over
and over again. Um, you guys remember uh
Madonna, of course, in a Rolling Stone
interview, Madonna said she felt like
she chneled sometimes when I'm writing
songs. I'm just channeling. I could say
that live to tell which is super famous
song was about my childhood, my
relationship with my parents, my father,
my stepmother, but maybe not
channeling just like um who was the
other guy? Uh Bob Dylan did um Jim
Morrison from the Doors, right? It's so
he had an interesting experience when he
was younger. He I guess witnessed a
traffic accident where a bunch of Native
Americans or Indians were all over the
road and they were all bleeding and all
that kind of stuff. And it really
traumatized him. But he says here, "The
rocker believed the souls of maybe one
or two of those Indians landed in his
own soul, which was like a sponge ready
to sit there and absorb it."
Sounds really dark to me. Um, yikes. I
don't think I want that to happen to me.
Um, and I'm not a sponge for some
demons. Um, by God's grace. Um,
interesting side note here. He actually
married a music journalist, Patricia
Kinley Kenny.
And uh Kenny practiced Celtic paganism
and in 1970 she and Morrison went in a
handfasting ceremony which involved
drops of blood. Now the his wife she
also served for a consultant on uh an
Oliver Stone movie which was in 1991 and
it was about the doors actually the band
that you know Jim Morrison was part of
and she made a cameo in there as a
priest as well priestess residing over
the marriage ceremony. So it was like
she was married with the blood ceremony
and all that and then in this movie she
was the priestess overlooking the
ceremony with the blood sacrifice. So
kind of weird. Once again you see the
counterfeit. I mean the devil's just
taking what what God meant for something
um spiritual. There's power in the
blood. The blood is what you know needs
to be sprinkled so that it covers our
sins. And you're talking about the blood
of Jesus. Yeah. Blood of Jesus. And and
you know here it's like the devil's just
using those elements but in just a
opposite way. Mhm. Mhm. So you talked
earlier about Beyonce. Uh this is a very
famous clip about how she talks about
something came into her all of a sudden.
Listen to what Beyonce said in an
interview with BET. And I remember right
before I performed, I raised my hands up
and it was kind of the first time I I
felt something else come into me. And I
knew that was going to be my coming out
night.
And um I'm really kind of shy and not
really shy, but more reserved and um
nothing like Sasha.
But I guess I wouldn't be very
entertaining on the stage. So Sasha
comes out and she's fearless.
You know, she can she can do things that
I cannot do when I'm in rehearsal. I
mean, I can try, but then it just
doesn't happen. I can sing notes and
sing strong and do all these things that
when I'm just by myself, I can't do. So,
like when you're getting ready to go on
stage and perform, does Sasha Fierce,
when does she show up? Usually when I
hear the crowd, when I put on my
stilettos, um when like the the moment
right before when you're nervous and and
that other thing kind of takes over for
you. Uhhuh. And I it's no different from
anyone else. I feel like we all kind of
have that that thing that takes over. Uh
you know, this is common between
celebrities. You got Beyonce. There's
also uh Slim Shady. Yeah. Eminem
and other thing in other people because
somehow talent doesn't take you talent
may take you far but talent doesn't take
you that far. Yeah. Right. Because
talent comes from God. God gives us you
know gifts and talents. But when it
comes to the point where you're not
really glorifying God in any way and the
devil wants to like up on that then he
can use you. And you know, some people
may think, oh, the devil can't really
like give you anything. But we have the
the example in Mark 5 with the with the
man that was demonpossessed with legion,
right? It's like, we are legion. We are
many. That man has super uh natural
strength. Mhm. Right. He he could they
would try to uh get him arrested. He
would break the chains. He would break
the everything. And the devil can't
really just use you and give things that
you do not possess yourself. Yeah. Um,
actually Jim Morrison, who we just
talked about, he also had a pseudonym uh
or an alter ego called the lizard king.
So it's kind of weird, but you know,
they they all do it. There's so many of
them. Um, and then also, of course, we
have Katy Perry. She was raised by I
think it was Pentecostal pastors as
parents. Uh, don't correct me on the
Pentecostal thing, but she she there's
also a clip, but she's like, "Well, I
wanted to be like the Amy Grant of
Christian music, but then uh I sold my
soul to the devil." And then she's doing
all these pagan rituals on stage, too.
And then we got David Bowie. Uh, there
was a Rolling Stone interview. Actually,
it was not really an interview. It was
more like this this journalist followed
him around for a couple days as he was
recording in a studio and doing things
and talked to him once in a while. And
he's talking about rock and roll
specifically. He says, this is David
Bowie speaking, it will occupy and
destroy you that way. It lets in the
lower elements and shadows that I don't
think are necessary. Rock has always
been the devil's music. You can't
convince me that it isn't. I just find
it super interesting that that he says
this and that he says it about a genre
and and we'll take a look in a second
how Rod Long says the same thing about
hip-hop that like the genre is the
devil's music.
Interesting. So, a couple uh of months
ago, we put out this video, NBA never
broke again. A young boy, he's a I guess
you call him hip-hop artist. He said
some interesting stuff about the music
industry as well. Cuz what I learned is
it's a it's a is a the industry that I
chose to be a part of. So it's like I I
accept that I run with it. But don't be
a dumb at the same time. You got to
understand that using me is
entertainment
[Music]
comes to
I
know some can be spoke on why
is this too big Eat.
[Applause]
[Music]
Heat.
If you got nothing to do with the devil,
I don't think you'd be speaking like
that, saying those things, or making
those music videos. I think it's sad
because it's a counterfeit for um you
know, the idea of of of losing your
life, right? So their sacrifice is sort
of reversed. Um they're they're they're
finding their life in this one. Whereas
God is saying that um you know for those
that that lose their life will find
eternal life in the end. Yeah. And so
you know these guys are are recognizing
well if I cross this line and I do this
deal I might as well live it up because
I'm I'm going to pay for it later with
the with the life. So you either die now
or you die later. Everybody has to make
almost the same choice. Well, it's
interesting that Roger Mno, you know,
the former Satanist, in his interview,
we showed part of it earlier, um he he
actually mentions how
um a lot of these people who follow
Satan, who worship Satan, truly are
deceived and truly believe that he is an
angel of light and it means well for
them and that Satan will eventually
defeat Christ in this great battle
between good and evil and that all the
people who follow Satan will live
forever the way they want to live. Mhm.
And so when they, you know, it's the
same in the concept of narcissism, like
God is evil and Satan is good and he's
your savior and God is just just
annoying. Like he just makes you keep
some silly rules like the Ten
Commandments. So just follow Satan. And
so I think there's a lot of deception
going on in this but almost not because
he recognizes it, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So speaking of uh Roger Mau,
he has something to say about rock music
as well. He was interviewed by Pastor
Doug Bachelor has his church. Uh Pastor
Doug Bachelor is the president of
Amazing Facts, awesome ministry. We've
had him on our show before. And uh so
there was a a question from the audience
saying, "Hey, so my kid listens to rock
music. Can you tell me more about that?"
So this is what Roger Man says about
rock music. Rock music is a very
powerful snare that demon spirits are
using
uh to captivate
the young people and draw them away from
Christ and his protection. people who
experience
the rock music in snare
were in our home
uh in the fall of 1991
and were seeking very special help. They
came all the way from across the world.
Uh the parents are super wealthy and u
what happened here is that this man
married this fine young lady and um it
wasn't too long after that they started
to have some real problems
and um here's what happened.
They went on their honeymoon
and entering a big city,
they saw all these billboards and signs
talking about this this uh artist, rock
artist and his gang that was going to be
there playing while they were in the
rock concert.
U like the high priest used to say,
when a person enters an establishment
that is dedicated to the service of the
great master, meaning Satan. Yeah. Such
as astrologers, fortune tellers,
different capacities, hypnotists. Mhm.
And people like that. The angels of the
Lord are not able to come in there. But
he did say at one time that the spirit
of the creator could there was no limit
to the spirit of the creator. These rock
artists usually
uh dedicate the building or the the area
that's going to be covered by uh the
listeners. Mhm. They circle it three
times in one day or three times, three
consecutive days. And they they shout
they they sang a mitra which is a a a
prayer for possession. And they actually
prayed to the great master and his
angels that they will captivate every
young person that enters that area.
the the father phoned me up from from uh
across the world and said
our son-in-law and our daughter wants to
go to Endeott, New York to see you so
you can pray for her and she believes if
she be anointed that the whatever is
taking place that some type of
possession she was wrestling with. Yeah.
We noticed when she was visiting us that
she had something in her ear and a
little wire about behind her ear and
then into her hair and it was into her
handbag. Something in her handbag. She
had a little player that was playing
rock music
and he one morning came to see us
because he said my wife can't come
because she's been crying all night.
Uh but he said uh
we we hope that the ministry will agree
to anoint her, you know, etc. And I
asked him,
I said, "Let me ask you, is your wife
listening to rock music on her little
Walkman,
her little radio,
it was a cassette player, right? Tiny
little one." He said, "I had hoped that
you wouldn't ask me that question."
He said, "Yes."
And I explained to him, I said,
"Powerful spirits have found an avenue
to control your minds. I mean, your
wife's emotions." See, here here's the
way it goes. The high priest said that
the demon spirits love to play games
with Christians.
First of all, do you love to move upon
people's imagination
and to create strong feelings of anger,
fear, love
and uh grief they make they can create
all these feelings into people and
people believe it's their own that you
know it's their own being that feels
this way. Mhm. And then from there on I
told him how we're going to pray for his
wife. went back. She was anointed and
they went back home and things were not
any better. Things were worse
until one day daddy phoned me up and he
said, "Roger,
uh, my wife has had a terrible
experience
yesterday.
She is she doesn't have any broken
bones, but boy, did the spirits ever
ever do her in almost kill her." She
said, "I wasn't in in the kitchen and I
heard go down the hallway to the
bathroom. Then I heard this her yelling
and screaming and help help." Some
invisible being
grabbed her by the hair from the back,
brought her in in the bathroom and there
was a tile floor, chew her on her face
and bash her head until blood is flowing
all over from her nose. Her eyes were
cut above her eyes. Um, and he came and
he said he and he he said, "Dear Jesus,
please help." Mhm. Immediately the the
force gave up. Crazy, right? That is
crazy. From listening to that music.
Interesting. I was pretty shocked when I
when I heard that. Yeah. I used to be a
avid listener of rock music. I liked
everything like Nickelback. I I listened
to Metallica, which is kind of hinging
on more like um metal, um Red Hot Chili
Peppers, like everything AC/DC and uh
yeah, I was pretty shocked. I don't
listen to that anymore. I've been
listening a long time, but I was just
shocked when I heard this. We we find
this also in the Bible, something
similar with King Saul. Yes. And he was,
you know, uh disturbed by demons and
evil spirits. And it's interesting that
his servant, the the the king's servant
knew, hey, if you get someone to play
the harp and play some nice, you know,
songs Mhm. um the demons will go away.
Mhm. So even back then it was understood
that music and chanting in certain types
of genre could invoke spirits as well as
expel spirits. This is what this is what
Rottwong, Diddy's producer, also talked
about. And you know, it it's wild to me
that that this doesn't seem to be just
limited, this idea you're talking about
to rock music, but Rod, who was into
RBNB and hip-hop, was a producer for
that. He says the same thing about
hip-hop. I think that Satan's grip on
music.
It It's not just
uh genres that are not necessarily
Christian or gospel. I think they all
bottleneck into Satan. Um, and I think
that the gatekeepers in one are the same
as the gatekeepers in another. There
there's certain rituals you have to do
if you want to get to the top of the
industry. I used to ask God,
Lord, how come? Because I love the sound
of of R&B.
You know, I know that the lyrics
definitely don't honor God, but one of
my struggles was I can create that music
on a high level. Like, I love it. If I
get in the room and I get my gear, I can
create stuff that that the world would
like, right? So, I used to ask God, "How
come we I can't take this
and make this glorify you? How come I
can't take that sound and make it
glorify you? Which a lot of guys do.
They take R&B and they'll put gospel
lyrics on top of it and just say it's
gospel. And the Lord
the Lord spoke to me and said
whenever the spirit of God is made
manifest in a room,
the sound that is produced is not that
David would make sounds. He would make
sounds that would make demons leave
soul. Yes. He would produce and he
wasn't singing on them. He would just
play the sound and the demons that used
to possess and harass Saul would depart
from him. So that means that there's a
sound that draws spirits. There is a
sound or repel spirit. Yes. It's not
just rebuking with your mouth. You can
rebuke a demon with the right sound.
Yes. And so it's time, I guess, for the
church to stop borrowing their sound.
Absolutely. From the world and start
getting into the Holy Spirit. Yes. Hear
the sounds that he's making so that
those sounds can have a distinction that
can deal with the atmospheres that are
going on in America.
There's been moments where I'm playing
and I'm ministering and the Lord will
say, "Play this or play that." And I
know it's him. And as I do it, I
immediately see the manifestation in the
people. Somebody may begin to scream out
and a demon may, you know, start
manifesting just from no words are being
said at all. So, so yeah, he's talking
about, you know, now mixing this RBNB
and hip-hop with with Christian gospel
music. And he has one more warning for
Christians as we choose like what music
we listen to and even play in our
churches. A lot of artists in the gospel
world, they mimic R&B, they mimic
hip-hop. They are attracted to the sound
and it does not work. The gift still has
to be yielded for the use of the Holy
Ghost. Whenever the Lord shows up or he
manifests his presence in a room, it's
never the sound of R&B. It's never the
sound of hip-hop. It's always a pure
heavenly sound. If I was to go to a
diddy party and I was to start singing
Holy is the lamb, I would clear that
room out because it's a different sound.
It's going to shake that atmosphere and
people would immediately begin to feel
uncomfortable. And it's the same thing.
We should feel uncomfortable when those
sounds come into our atmosphere. Sadly,
in a lot of churches, they have adapted
that sound and they move forward in it.
Yeah. Wow. I I I recently saw a picture
of of some big like sort of DJ stuff and
and what caught my attention was they
were saying that this is all Christian
DJing like the laser lights and the you
know everybody dancing. It looked like
something that that they were out in
Vegas or something big like this, you
know, and it was just funny like to see
people acting exactly the same and if
they didn't mention that that was
Christianity and you just looked at it,
it there would be no distinction between
those two. Yeah. Um, just think of all
the drugs that happen and like cuz cuz
I'm from the Netherlands and
specifically Amsterdam is known for
producing a lot of the dance music. Mhm.
And uh and it's it's just directly
connected to drugs all the time like
specifically ecstasy, right? And then
like they're like, "Well, no, it's
Christian." Yeah. Interesting. Yeah. It
does not it does not work. Yeah, it
doesn't. And now, especially in social
media, there's been
uh getting to I don't know if it's
something that has been going on for a
while, but especially now the rise of
Christian rap is something that has been
happening. You know, just independent
creator, content creators just start
freestyling uh to a beat and putting,
you know, uh Bible lyrics on it or
something like that. And it's something
that is like um a lot of people are
doing it more than ever. And it's it's
yeah when you can't really tell the
difference, tell them apart, you know,
because let's say rap is is doesn't have
the cleanest reputation, right? Hip-hop
doesn't have the best reputation.
Neither does rock. I mean, rock and roll
literally means to rock and roll the car
because teenagers are having sex in the
car listening to the music. Exactly. I
mean, if you if you uh I haven't watched
the movie, but I heard the story of of
the out of Compton, straight out of
Compton movie in the in the history of
hip-hop, you know, it's not something
that we should be adapting to, you know,
uh church music or Christian putting
Christian lyrics on it. If it's always
associated with rebellion, always
associated with sinful pleasures and all
that kind of stuff, we should be apart
from the world, different from the
world. I I imagine these um these
spirits that leave because I've always
kind of thought about this like what
what would make why would they leave you
know what would make them like like just
flee away from you in that moment and I
and I think I don't have anything to
really back this up but I think that
it's probably because there's a certain
type of music or sound or something that
they remember heaven and it's like it
puts their mind right back there and
they probably remember where they fell
from and they can't stand it, you know,
and then they they leave. That's That's
what my guess is that that really makes
them leave is I think heaven has a
particular sound and the music that came
out of there and and it just reminds
them of their probably pure life and
they don't want to think about it. Yeah.
And from the Bible, what sounds do we
know that heaven has? What instruments
do we find there? The harp, the trumpet.
Yeah. There's a choir of angels, right?
We don't really see anything much other
than that, but we definitely don't see
the demonic deeds that are being used
today. I agree. You know, the Bible does
have something to say about this as
well. In First Thessalonians, it says,
"Abstain from every form of evil. Now,
may the God of peace himself sanctify
you completely, and may your whole
spirit, soul, and body be preserved
blameless at the coming of our Lord
Jesus Christ. He who calls you his
faith, well, he will also do He says,
"Abtain from all evil. I want to
sanctify you. I want to cleanse you so
that you'll be ready when Jesus comes."
And I believe he's coming very soon. And
I just want to encourage everybody to
take heed to the scriptures where it
says to abstain from evil. And 1 John 2
says, "Do not love the world or the
things in the world. If anyone loves the
world, the love of the father is not in
him. For all that is in the world, the
lust of the flesh, the lust of the eyes,
and the pride of life is not of the
father, but is of the world." And then 2
Corinthians 6 says, "Do not be unequally
yolked together with unbelievers. For
what fellowship has righteousness with
lawlessness?" What is lawlessness
according to the Bible? Sin. Sin. Yeah.
Sin is the transgression of the law. The
Bible says, "And what communion has
light with darkness? And what accord has
Christ with bleial? Or what part has a
believer with an unbeliever? And what
agreement has the temple of God with
idols? For you are the temple of the
living God. As God has said, I will
dwell in them and walk among them. I
will be their God and they shall be my
people. Therefore, come out from among
them and be separate, says the Lord. Do
not touch what is unclean and I will
receive you. You know the word that the
name Emmanuel actually means God with
us. That's what Jesus wanted to do. He
wants to dwell inside of us. He wants to
cleanse us. He wants to sanctify us. And
he wants to make us ready for his coming
to be a pure and holy people reflecting
his character, reflecting his image. And
he says, "Abstain from these things."
And he doesn't just say it, he gives us
the strength to do it because
Philippians 4:13 says, "I can do all
things through Christ who strengthens
me." So no matter how hard a temptation
is, you know, he can set you free. He
can make you clean. And you know, I
think we've all experienced this. the
closer we come to Jesus and and the more
he asks us to leave behind as much as
it's a temptation, it's a struggle. When
you do it and you come to the other
side, you realize this is so much
better, you know, to keep walking in the
Lord's ways. Amen. If you like this
video, like, subscribe, and hit the
notification bell so you know when we
launch new videos. And drop a comment
below, and we'll try to get back to you
if we can. What?
Say that again. Oh, no. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]